[Musique]
l'humain n'est plus au coeur de notre
mission d'accompagnement des personnes
âgées alors même que certains ehpad
génère des profits substantiels
madame la ministre ma double question
est simple le rapport libos sur le grand
âge et l'autonomie qui vient de vous
être me fait des propositions quand
seront elles mises en oeuvre avec quels
financements dédiés
l'urgence est là nous ne pouvons plus
attendre
il ya urgence à agir il ya trop
longtemps que nous reculons devant cet
obstacle parce que effectivement cela
nécessite une réorganisation complète du
secteur ainsi que des financements
conséquents pour améliorer la prise en
charge de nos aînés augmenter le nombre
de personnels auprès des personnes âgées
améliorer la prise en charge à domicile
revaloriser les métiers et tout cela
sont évidemment les pistes tracées par
le rapport de dominique libault qui m'a
été remis le 28 mars un groupe de
travail en urgence va m'apporter des
conclusions sur la revalorisation des
métiers de la personne autour de la
personne âgée je pense que c'est
l'urgence aujourd'hui pour rendre ces
métiers de nouveau attractif et veiller
à la bientraitance des personnes âgées
mais au delà de ça nous remettrons
évidemment un projet de loi avant la fin
d'année
sur la base du rapport qui m'a été remis
avec 975 proposition de dominique
libault qui sont en cours d'instruction
et qui vont être travaillées avec les
différentes parties prenantes dans un
espace de concertation
tout cela sera prêt avant la fin de
l'année je me suis engagé devant les
français je vous remercie
à mesure que les français découvrent
votre projet de loi pour l'école leur
colère grandit les nombreuses actions
organisées aujourd'hui est en ce moment
même en témoigne la création des
établissements publics des savoirs
fondamentaux cristallise les
mécontentements concevoir un
établissement unique école collège sous
gouvernance de ce dernier s'est porté
une attaque sans précédent à l'école
dans ces établissements
les directeurs d'école disparaîtrait au
profit de chefs d'établissement et
d'adjoints davantage missionné pour
gérer la pénurie de moyens que pour
porter un projet pédagogique et
accompagner les élèves venant serez vous
à la création des établissements publics
des savoirs fondamentaux qui n'ont
d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'aucune
concertation ni avec la communauté
éducative ni avec les associations de
maires pourtant concerné au premier chef
je vous remercie pour votre question qui
me donne l'occasion de donner quelques
éléments de clarification et peut-être
de vous rassurer parce qu'au fond il ya
beaucoup d'éléments dans votre question
qui ne sont pas exacts premièrement
premièrement c'est l'occasion de puisque
je viens d avoir de vous donner les
chiffres de la mobilisation qui est deux
qui donnent donc en moyenne premier et
second degré 7 8%
et s'agissant du premier degré 14 8%
c'est d'ailleurs 10 points de moins que
la grève qui a eu lieu le 25 mars
dernier
le fait est que l'établissement public
des savoirs fondamentaux
je les dis est une option ce n'est
certainement pas quelque chose
d'obligatoire
c'est quelque chose qui réclamera à
l'accord et du conseil des écoles dont
des principaux intéressés et du collège
bien entendu mais aussi des élus locaux
j'aurai l'occasion de le dire devant
cette chambre puisque ce sera au mois de
mai que vous l'examinerait et vous me
dites que ça n'a pas été discuté
précédemment ça fait d'abord des
dizaines d'années que cette que cette
mesure et dont je dirais dans l'est dans
les discussions dans le débat public
mais surtout je suis un peu étonné qu'on
me surpris qu'on me reproche de jouer le
jeu du débat parlementaire c'est-à-dire
nous avons pris un abandon à l'assemblée
nationale nous prendrons certainement
des amendements ici nous améliorons
certainement le texte et j'imagine mal
que vous puissiez nous le reprocher
[Musique]
ce